The road ahead is not going to be easy.
It never is, especially for folks like you and me.
We've both felt the sting of those daily slights throughout our entire lives.
The folks who crossed the street in fear of their safety.
The clerks who kept a close eye on us in all those department stores.
The people at formal events who assumed we were the help.
And those who have questioned our intelligence, our honesty,...
...even our love of this country.
And I know that these little indignities are obviously nothing...
...compared to what folks across the country are dealing with every single day.
Those nagging worries that you're gonna get stopped...
...or pulled over for absolutely no reason.
The fear that your job application will be overlooked because of the way your name sounds.
The agony of sending your kids to schools that may no longer be separate,...
...but are far from equal.
The realization that no matter how far you rise in life,...
...how hard you work to be a good person, a good parent, a good citizen,...
...for some folks, it will never be enough.
But graduates, today I wanna be very clear that those feelings are not an excuse...
...to just throw up our hands and give up.
Not an excuse.
They are not an excuse to lose hope.